i don't know what's going on in the nfc
yeah at this point right the cowboys
were three and oh yeah now they're three
and two the rams were three and oh
now they're three and two yeah the
packers are four and one the saints are
four and one the bears are three and two
i don't know who the best team in the
conference is well the the first thing
i'll say is the conference is damn good
i mean that's the first thing we got to
talk about you know the nfc is legit it
is certainly a more in-depth conference
than the afc who were not really sure
who the third best team is and like we
said last hour it's the buffalo bills
you can't really argue it they're four
and one uh and they're tied with the
kansas city chiefs for the second best
record in the conference but the nfc
yeah the cowboys okay right you know oh
gosh they're great but man they had to
play the saints and the packers the last
two weeks both of those teams are really
good you know the seahawks lost to the
saints at home the saints losses to the
rams in la you know it's so they've had
to play each other i still think the nfc
yes we don't know what it's all about
san francisco is the only undefeated
team there i think they are legit as
well they're going to be in this
conversation for one of the better teams
in the nfc i think they're out here but
i think some of these guys might have a
little bit more of a underwhelming
record when we're all said and done not
because they're not good teams but
because the nfc is going to be
beat each other up yeah i agree with you
and the question becomes
does the team that emerges from that
morass is that team better suited yeah
taking down the patriots of the chiefs
or is that team limping to the finish
line that'll be big especially like a
team from the nfc north yeah when you
think about how all of them are above
500 right right right and they're going
to beat the crap out of each other
repeatedly they've already done it a few
times we've seen packers bears we've
seen packers vikings bears vikings we
have packers lines coming up next monday
night and then nfc norse play in the nfc
east which has the cowboys and the
eagles and we go geez louise so i mean
yes i didn't mean to cut you off no no
you're fine but i i i really don't know
and we have
12 weeks of the regular season left
right 11 games for most teams here are
the 49ers though sitting at 3-0 they
haven't played a game in 15 days they're
the last undefeated team in the nfc and
we didn't even bring them up yet no i
know i just said them but you weren't
listening you don't sound yeah but
you're right when i was going through
the whole thing with all the teams at
the top no i don't listen
no you don't but yeah well i think the
one thing you see from the nfc teams is
this is the one broad thing i look at
when you go 49ers saints green bay
dallas seattle okay even get into
philadelphia and minnesota and the rams
territory i look at all of them and go
man
all those teams i just mentioned
physical upfront on the offensive side
of the ball can run it and then have
defensive lines that are legit too where
they can go hey front four you handle
the run hey front four you get after the
quarterback we don't need to like
compromise ourselves and do stupid
things because we can win these battles
up front and that's where i look at the
nfc and just go they have a clear
advantage over the afc other than the
patriots where they're just uh a lot of
big physical teams in the nfc right now
is there a team in the nfc
that is lingering that could get hot and
disrupt our thinking i i i mean i look
at that team to be the carolina panthers
i look and again i'm biased i had the
panthers going to the nfc championship
game but i still think anybody out there
that's watching football you
realistically got to look at them and go
okay there's there's some traits here
that translate to
whoa this team could be good and kyle
allen's done a great job but let's again
he's been really good he ain't cam
newton when cam newton's totally healthy
and if they can get cam newton back in
the fold because their defense is one of
the best in football they found a pass
rush now with bruce irvin back in the
lineup and brian burns has been
phenomenal and mario addison off the
edge they can run the ball with mighty
mouse i mean mighty mouse is amazing
okay christian mccaffrey he really is i
mean he's one of the best offensive
players in football uh so they really
have a lot of aspects to where i go
watch out for them if uh you know they
can get cam out there hitting on all
cylinders at some point the next few
weeks and there's an argument to be made
that i don't want to say they're better
yeah without cam newton
but not having cam newton on the field
removes a lot of this institutional
angst sure dealing with should we run
him more should we run him less right is
he a pocket pass right should he change
his throwing motion he's really creative
can we do right he's got this talented
skill set should we invent some crazy
new plays for him i mean i think you're
right mike you know what they can do you
know what they can do they can embrace
him when he's healthy when he's truly
healthy right you embrace him and you no
longer have to worry about him getting
injured yeah because you know if he gets
injured you just go back to kyle really
great point right you're right they're
gonna be able to go you know we can play
this to the edge a little bit more oh
it's third and two you know okay hey we
got kyle allen smash it up in there cam
newton you know and get us the first
down and cam newton just like drew brees
who's doing thumb exercises all night
now because he's going damn it looks
like they don't need me he's going to be
motivated as hell he's going to be
motivated as hell too just like drew
brees he's probably doing ankle and
exercises right now and foot exercises
because he's going damn
nobody's going to think they need me
here and so he's going to come back like
on point i really think that when he
does come back because he's not going to
want to hear that narrative it's it's
strange for guys like cam newton and
drew brees to get a glimpse of what life
will be like right without them yeah in
the future
they're getting it now yeah they're
seeing that the train is going to keep
rolling that the franchise is not going
to disband simply because the franchise
quarterback is gone and that can be very
sobering but it also can be very
motivating and it has clearly made drew
brees determined to get back there was
the video from over the weekend of him
throwing the football now we didn't see
where the football went right right so
he still was throwing it but i'm i'm
told three weeks yeah arizona cardinals
actually 20 days from now that's the
realistic return date but meanwhile
they're fine without him and teddy
bridgewater is becoming the guy
that we thought he would be in 2016 the
year that he tore up his name right and
he told me yesterday he said that knee
is not an issue that knee's stronger
than it was before it happened because
of all the time he spent working on it
and working on it right and and this i
knew sean payton was going to do this i
didn't know it was going to work so well
but sean payton's the master of figuring
out what a defense is going to give you
yeah there's only 11 guys over there
right you just figure out where they
aren't and you put your guys there and
that's what he does every week if it's
seattle and they're down the field and
they're taking away the deep stuff you
throw short if it's dallas you gotta get
into a grind out physical game they do
they can do the bucks and they're gonna
take chances you can beat him deep you
beat him deep yeah exactly right he's
one of the greatest coaches we've seen i
mean sean payton is really really
special
definitely one of the greatest offensive
minds we've ever seen what people don't
give him enough credit for is his
toughness and physicality sean
payton's teams play with and i gotta
give dennis allen a lot of credit too i
feel like he's kind of adjusted his
approach a little bit on the defensive
side of the ball stop being so
man-to-man aggressive he's been changing
up coverages a little bit i think that's
really given them a good advantage but
hey dennis allen
was a failed former raiders coach right
at some point right he's going to start
getting noticed for another opportunity
because you know you look at the
dysfunction that the raiders had all
those years from 2002 and through 2018.
you can say hey you know what this this
guy
wouldn't be the first one who failed in
his first stint and then went on to be a
good coach elsewhere definitely not and
he's gotten to go to a place where
i'm sure he's learned a lot of football
i mean having defend sean payton and
practice all training camp you know year
after year i mean hampshire he's got a
lot of new tricks up his sleeve now as
far as what he wants to do as a
defensive coordinator or if he does
become a head coach but yeah that's the
thing that just jumps out to me i mean
there's just some really well-rounded
teams in the nfc
and you know we're we're seeing i mean
hey oh franchise quarterback out doesn't
run oh no andrew luck oh the colts are
three and two oh no cam newton no you
know there's the carolina panthers 3-0
without him same thing with the saints
it's just uh teams win games and um
these these are teams that have found
ways to re-orchestrate their attack
without their franchise quarterbacks at
what point yeah does this dynamic
cause someone i know this is this is
already going on there's some
conversations with people i talked to in
the nfl already where this be i know
we're going to go when a guy comes up
for a new contract
and and and uh hey 28 million 30 million
32 million 34 million nah you know what
we'll just find a fifth rounder we'll
groom somebody right we'll find somebody
who fits our system we're not going to
allow the
franchise to be held hostage by one
person's enormous
financial demands because unl you know i
think that the term
franchise quarterback yeah
is going to be
narrower it's going to be patrick
mahomes right russell wilson deshawn
watson not like every guy in football
every guy who's good enough that we're
afraid that what are we gonna do without
him so we better pay him market value
right we've seen an explosion in the
market starting with the andrew luck
contract then derek carr then matthew
stafford then kirk cousins jimmy
garoppolo matt ryan and it's just it's
like you know the game where you put
your hand up the baseball bat like
everybody goes a little bit higher a
little bit higher yeah well at some
point somebody's getting to the top and
they're going to say that's it yeah
they're not going to do it trubisky
right he may be the first one to hear
you might be not going to do it right i
i i we thought it was going to be jared
goff yeah and they ended up paying jared
goff and and look we've kind of
forgotten about the rams they did look
great offensively he played good again
he played really well i know he made a
lot of big throws just like he did the
week before in the tampa bay game where
i know i came out on monday and i was
like it was shaky and then i know you
know i self-scattered myself as i
watched film no that's starting to catch
on i'm glad yeah i'm glad i know you
sent me a text who said it casey yeah
kirk herb street said he self-scouted
himself yeah that's good hey that's what
you we should be doing out there as
analysts is you know at some point we
got to go back and evaluate what we're
saying and see you know is it holding up
true to what you see on film when you
study the game and jared goff has made a
lot of big time throws this year and
yeah i mean he is he is
really improved i i will say that much i
don't know whether to give you credit
for self scouted himself
josh allen no because when josh allen
was coming out in the draft i
interviewed him in like three different
times he said during the interview i
have a lot of self-confidence in myself
oh right no it was me first okay oh he
got it from that yeah probably
at that time you guys uh had a catch
although there was somebody else there
to actually do the catch that's what
quarterbacks do i'm a franchise
quarterback i don't touch the ball like
that
all right uh let's uh let's take a break
here bottom line is 11 of 16 teams in
the nfc are above 500. yeah 11 of them
right and that's not sustainable the
eagles are 10th in the nfc at 3 and 2.
the eagles were my
pre-season super bowl pick and i hate it
too once they get to sean jackson back
if they ever get him back and some help
in the secondary yeah yeah that too
right how do they get a lander skander
oh yeah you're right
it's problem solved it's just amazing
well they were playing the jets yeah
that had something to do with it yeah
but you know the eagles could be five
and oh yeah they should have won could
have won i'm not gonna say should have
won could have won both of the games
they lost yes and didn't and they go to
minnesota hey two three and two teams
getting together in six days in
minnesota that should be a good
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports